This is a really nice place you have, Kathy.
Yes, I really love the way you've decorated it, too.
Thanks guys. I'm glad you like it here.
I hope you can come visit me more often.
You can count on it!
Oops! Oh no! I just dropped my glass on your table.
I'm terribly sorry Kathy.
Hey, don't worry about it. No big deal.
Okay. Uh, Kathy. I hate to tell you this,...
...but I think the glass scratched the table a bit when it fell on it.
I'd like to apologize to you for my mistake.
Oh, that's just a tiny little scratch.
Oh, I'm so sorry. I will pay to get it fixed.
It won't happen again.
No, it's not even worth worrying about.
It's not really your fault, since the glass was slippery.